oh wow so this is kind of like a big
deal huh I knew that this was such a big
deal is absolutely no way that I would
have agreed to speak in public it's a
lot of really really cool people here um
hi I love you and I love I love you too
sorry it's even but yeah there are some
people that can make me leave the house
and the next recipient is one of them I
was lucky enough to be working with her
on the set of pitch perfect 3 she's very
professional I especially enjoyed the
impromptu dancing that she would do when
she's off camera and I have something
important to say to really really find
it's like um like a rare skill that I
think that even though there's a lot of
skilled women in here I think she is a
skill that nobody else has and that is
that she can do this sort of it's like
she looks like a cat like a cat that
accidentally got spiked with coffee and
doesn't know how to express his feelings
so it does it's like interpretive dance
that's what she likes to do to distract
people when she's acting with them it's
awesome on top of that she's a
critically acclaimed actor author and
singer and the real kicker is that
despite her success talent bathing looks
she remains humble and totally relatable
except for the whole being nominated for
an Oscar things she's officially the
most amazing overshare on Twitter yet
remains so like totally mysterious she's
classy with a sprinkle of sassiness and
other as I think we all know there's
some people that should not have Twitter
one person in particular this girl is
probably the queen of Twitter please
welcome Anna Kendrick oh it's nice I
like that over caffeinated cat or
whatever that was good I'm proud of that
I think this is amazing and I'm so happy
to be here I'm so honored to be here my
literary agent is here because I have a
literary agent because I'm incredibly
important and intellectual and I'm
basically James Joyce's he did vagina
joke and she told me you know they
usually give this award to traditional
authors which is her way of saying real
authors so [ __ ] you
but actually since the since it's about
the book I wanted to mention because I
am an oversharer one of the things I say
in the book is that sometimes when when
we wear these dresses they're borrowed
and they've been worn by by models
before and sometimes those models have
Bo and you don't know it until you're at
the event wearing the dress so that's
not me
if you stuff's not me that's a very
glamorous but smelly runway model so
nobody gets too close Ruby don't stand
too close to Santa and also because
you're impossibly glamorous and cool
please don't stand very close to me I
just wanted to say glamour UK gave me my
first I get a lot of this tonight but my
first real photo shoot you put me in
Paris and ran me around the streets of
Paris and chanel and Dior and I was so
amazing me I know and I felt so amazing
about it and I and I ripped open the
pages and I was I was just so excited I
looked like like really glamorous and
and then the the section rights before
that was I think Lily Collins against a
white background
still just outdoing me by a mile
perfectly proportioned Lily Collins and
then I thought no no I'm a babe I'm a
destroyer of male world I can yeah I do
all right you know Ruby Rose please
don't stand too close to me so this is
amazing and thank you so much and I just
want to say I love this city and I love
this country and any excuse to come here
thank you for giving me one I love it
here so much even though I keep seeing
advertisements for something called love
island which looks terrifying I don't
know what that is
in spite of that this is one of the most
fabulous and resilient places I ever
ever have the pleasure to visit so thank
you so much copay fee and good night
[Music]